Générique
...
- Alexandre Poussart:
Très heureux
de vous retrouver
pour "Parlement hebdo",
l'émission qui revient
sur les temps forts
de l'actualité
de la semaine au Parlement.
- Kathia Gilder:
Bonjour, Xavier Iacovelli.
Vous êtes sénateur
des Hauts-de-Seine,
membre de la majorité.
Vous êtes vice-président
de la commission
des Affaires sociales au Sénat.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Le projet de loi immigration
arrive à l'Assemblée nationale.
Un débat à haut
risque se dessine
pour Gérald Darmanin.
Il doit trouver
une majorité de députés
pour voter ce texte.
Le Sénat a adopté le budget
de la Sécurité sociale
pour 2024 dans une version
remaniée.
La majorité de droite
sénatoriale
a estimé
que le texte proposé
par le gouvernement
allait creuser
les déficits.
Les sénateurs ont voté
une proposition
de loi qui reconnaît
l'injustice
de la criminalisation
de l'homosexualité
en France entre 1942 et 1982.
La majorité de droite
s'est opposée
à des réparations financières.
- Kathia Gilder:
L'Assemblée nationale
se penche sur le projet
de loi immigration.
Le texte a été voté
par les sénateurs
dans une version durcie.
Il comprend deux volets,
l'un sécuritaire
et l'autre
sur l'intégration,
avec la question
de la régularisation
dans les métiers en tension.
Cette semaine, Gérald Darmanin
a été auditionné.
- Pour Gérald Darmanin,
c'est un double défi:
il doit convaincre
une partie des oppositions
sans perdre le soutien
des députés
du camp présidentiel.
Pour cette première
audition à l'Assemblée,
le ministre de l'Intérieur
défend l'équilibre
de sa loi.
- Simplification
drastique des procédures,
intégration notamment
par la langue,
le travail de fermeté
est extrêmement fort
contre les délinquants étrangers.
Voilà l'ossature du projet.
- Le texte, durci
par le Sénat,
fait bondir la gauche.
Pour La France Insoumise,
ce projet criminalise
les étrangers.
Même les socialistes,
pas totalement hostiles
au départ, sont sceptiques.
- On devait examiner
un texte méchant
avec les méchants
et gentil
avec les gentils.
On se retrouve
avec un texte méchant
avec tout le monde.
- Le Rassemblement
National dénonce
le laxisme et alerte
sur une vague
de régularisation de clandestins.
Avec la droite,
la pomme de discorde,
c'est l'article 3,
supprimé et réécrit
par le Sénat.
Gérald Darmanin
ne veut pas revenir
à la version initiale
pour ne pas braquer
la droite sénatoriale.
Il doit convaincre ses propres
troupes d'accepter
des modifications.
- Je proposerai
à notre commission
que nous puissions
trouver une solution
qui ne soit ni le droit
automatique général
et absolu, qui pose
des difficultés réelles,
ni le pouvoir
discrétionnaire du préfet,
tel que le Sénat a pu le prévoir.
- Pas sûr que cela suffise
à convaincre
Les Républicains.
- Seule une réforme
de la Constitution assurera
une pleine effectivité
de ce texte, redonnera
à la France le droit
d'accueillir
sur son sol qui elle veut
et la possibilité
de se protéger d'une
immigration massive
et subie qui porte atteinte
aux intérêts fondamentaux
de la nation.
- Gérald Darmanin
n'est qu'au début
des négociations
pour éviter un 49.3.
- Kathia Gilder:
Alors, Xavier Iacovelli,
sincèrement,
quand on voit les positions
des uns et des autres,
ça semble mission impossible
pour convaincre tout le monde.
Vous croyez que Gérald
Darmanin va réussir
à trouver une majorité
sur ce texte?
- Xavier Iacovelli:
Je crois en la capacité
de Gérald Darmanin
de convaincre
et de faire en sorte
de trouver un compromis
sur un texte
important et attendu
par les Français.
Il l'a démontré au Sénat.
La presse nous disait
qu'il était impossible
qu'on puisse faire
céder et trouver
un compromis avec les LR
sur la question
de la régularisation
des travailleurs
dans les métiers en tension.
On a supprimé
l'article 3
et on l'a réécrit
dans l'article 4 bis.
On a donc bien
la régularisation
des travailleurs
pour les métiers
en tension.
- Kathia Gilder:
Ca ne va pas plaire
aux députés LR.
- Xavier Iacovelli:
Je vous rappelle
qu'il y a des progrès
qui ont eu lieu.
En commission,
il y avait eu la suppression
des articles 2,
5 et 8, notamment
sur le durcissement
des sanctions
contre les employeurs
qui employaient
des travailleurs sans papiers.
Ca avait été supprimé
par la majorité LR
en commission.
Ca a été réintroduit
après discussion
avec le gouvernement.
Le gouvernement
et Gérald Darmanin
ont réussi à convaincre
la majorité sénatoriale
de réintroduire
ces dispositifs
dans la loi.
Je crois en la capacité
du ministre
de l'Intérieur
de trouver un compromis.
C'est une loi attendue
par les Français.
Ils attendent qu'on puisse
à la fois durcir
notre politique
migratoire
avec ceux qui n'ont pas
vocation
à être sur notre territoire,
de pouvoir expulser
ceux qui commettent
de la délinquance
dans notre pays,
et mieux intégrer
par la langue, avant tout.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Sur l'article 3,
sur la régularisation
des travailleurs sans-papiers
dans les métiers
en tension,
est-ce qu'il faut garder
la version sénatoriale
de cette mesure qui prévoit
des régularisations
à la discrétion du préfet?
Ca va permettre
de trouver un compromis?
- Xavier Iacovelli:
J'étais sur la version initiale,
qui était un renforcement,
une régularisation automatique,
mais avec des critères
fixés
par le Parlement.
Le Sénat a décidé de retirer
les prérogatives
au Parlement et de les donner
aux préfets, donc
au gouvernement.
Ca me va bien aussi.
La version sortie
du Sénat me va bien.
Une des lignes rouges,
et on l'a réaffirmé
dans nos discussions
et dans nos explications
de vote,
c'est la question de l'AME,
qui a été supprimée
par la majorité sénatoriale.
On a l'habitude de dire
que le Sénat corrige
les excentricités
de l'Assemblée nationale,
et là, c'est l'inverse,
on attend
que nos collègues députés
puissent réintroduire
cette triple
faute de la part
de la majorité sénatoriale.
- Kathia Gilder:
Les députés de droite
et du Rassemblement
National estiment
que ça va créer un appel d'air.
- Xavier Iacovelli:
Je pense
qu'ils n'ont pas lu le texte.
Il n'y a pas d'appel d'air.
Surtout quand on régularise
les gens
qui sont déjà
sur le territoire
et qui travaillent déjà
dans des métiers
en tension.
Il n'y a pas d'appel
d'air à ce niveau-là.
C'est un faux procès.
- Kathia Gilder:
A condition
d'être trois ans
sur le territoire français.
Ca
ne va pas bénéficier
à ceux qui ne sont pas en France.
- Xavier Iacovelli:
Et heureusement!
Ce n'est pas la volonté.
Le but,
c'est d'intégrer
ceux qui sont déjà
sur le territoire
et sortir de cette hypocrisie...
Même le tissu économique,
le MEDEF, demande
cette régularisation.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Les députés
Les Républicains
ont dit
qu'ils ne voteraient pas
ce texte
à cause de l'article
sur les régularisations,
même dans la version
modifiée
par les sénateurs
Les Républicains.
Est-ce que le gouvernement,
avec cette majorité incertaine
sur ce texte, doit
risquer d'utiliser
le 49.3 pour passer en force?
Est-ce qu'il faut
l'utiliser
sur ce texte, sachant
que le gouvernement
a droit à un seul 49.3
dans cette session parlementaire?
- Xavier Iacovelli:
On ne le souhaite pas.
Moi le premier.
Si la majorité
est incertaine,
la Première ministre prendra
la responsabilité
qui est la sienne
d'engager celle
de son gouvernement.
Il va falloir aussi
que les LR expliquent
à leur électorat
qu'une loi
qui est attendue
par les Français...
On n'est pas sur le principe
des retraites.
Il y a des divergences
entre le Sénat
et l'Assemblée
nationale au niveau
du groupe Les Républicains.
Les désaccords
qu'il y avait sur une loi
comme les retraites,
qui n'était
pas populaire...
Là, cette loi est attendue
par les Français.
- Kathia Gilder:
Un 49.3 populaire?
- Xavier Iacovelli:
En tout cas,
une loi attendue
par les Français,
donc un 49.3
avec la responsabilité
du gouvernement
engagée
si on ne trouve pas en accord.
Le but
est de trouver
un accord avant les fêtes de Noël.
- Kathia Gilder:
Si 49.3 il y a,
il y a un risque
de motion de censure.
Elle pourrait aboutir?
- Xavier Iacovelli:
Il va falloir, s'il
y a motion de censure,
qu'on nous explique comment
la gauche vote une motion
de censure déposée
par Les Républicains
sur une loi
sur l'immigration
qui durcit les règles
de régularisation.
Il va falloir
qu'ils soient cohérents.
Je pense
qu'il est plus important
de trouver un compromis
sur ce texte attendu
par les Français
plutôt que d'aller
sur des postures politiciennes.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Les députés LR conditionnent
leur vote à une réforme
de la Constitution,
notamment sur le sujet migratoire.
Etes-vous favorable
à cette réforme?
- Xavier Iacovelli:
Je ne suis pas favorable.
Je pense que la porte
est fermée
sur la modification,
sur la question
de l'immigration.
- Kathia Gilder:
Ce n'est pas une bonne idée?
- Xavier Iacovelli:
On ne doit pas toucher
la Constitution sur ces sujets.
Il y a des lois
importantes, attendues.
On a un Parlement
qui est là pour ça.
On n'est pas obligé
de mettre ça
dans la Constitution.
- Kathia Gilder:
Nouveau sujet
qui vous concerne.
Le Sénat a voté le budget
de la Sécurité sociale
pour 2024.
La majorité de la droite
et du centre
a remanié largement le texte.
Des hausses de taxes
sur les boissons
et les aliments sucrés
ont été ajoutées
par la Haute Assemblée.
- C'est désormais
un classique: le Sénat
a réécrit la version
gouvernementale
pour finalement
adopter son projet
de loi de financement
de la Sécurité sociale.
La majorité de droite
et du centre
a commencé comme l'an
dernier par rejeter
la trajectoire
financière présentée
par le gouvernement
et qui prévoit
un trou de la Sécu
qui passerait
de 8,8 milliards en 2023 à 17,5
milliards d'euros
en 2025.
- La trajectoire
qui est proposée sera
de plus en plus déficitaire.
Pourquoi?
L'assurance
maladie coûte
de plus en plus cher.
Les Français
sont de plus en plus insatisfaits.
- Le gouvernement
s'est défendu
de ne pas être soucieux
des comptes publics
et a renvoyé au Sénat
la responsabilité
d'avoir lui aussi
aggravé ce déficit
avec de nombreuses
modifications coûteuses.
- A l'issue de ces débats,
le déficit
de la Sécurité sociale
se retrouve aggravé
de plus de 1,3
milliard d'euros
par des dépenses
supplémentaires
et des moindres recettes.
- Les sénateurs
ont reporté la réforme
de la tarification
à l'activité,
la jugeant mal préparée.
Ils ont voté une consultation
du Parlement
en cas d'augmentation
des franchises médicales
ou adopté le principe d'une
somme forfaitaire
à payer en cas d'absence
à un rendez-vous médical,
baptisée "taxe lapin".
Le Sénat a voté
plusieurs taxes
sur les produits
trop sucrés ou contenant
trop d'additifs contre l'avis
du gouvernement.
- Les additifs
de toutes sortes
sont à l'origine
de maladies chroniques,
avec des complications sévères.
Ca nuit à votre santé,
votre confort
de vie, et vous voulez
vous en prendre
au pouvoir d'achat?
- La version sénatoriale a été
votée uniquement
par des membres du groupe LR
et Union centriste.
- Kathia Gilder:
Xavier Iacovelli,
il n'y a à nouveau pas eu
d'accord
entre députés et sénateurs
sur ce budget
de la Sécu.
Jeudi, le gouvernement
est passé
en force à l'Assemblée
sur ce budget.
Que se passe-t-il?
Le gouvernement
ne dialogue
plus avec le Parlement?
- Xavier Iacovelli:
Il n'est pas passé
en force.
Il a utilisé un élément
de la Constitution
qui engage la responsabilité
du gouvernement
sur une question budgétaire.
Il n'y a rien d'exceptionnel.
C'est comme ça
dans toutes les collectivités
normales.
L'opposition vote
contre le budget,
la majorité vote pour.
Quand on a une majorité
relative,
il n'est pas anormal d'engager
la responsabilité
du gouvernement.
- Kathia Gilder:
Mais il n'y
a plus de dialogue.
- Xavier Iacovelli:
Il y a eu un dialogue.
Pour avoir assisté
à toutes les séances
du Sénat...
Le Sénat est majoritairement
dans l'opposition.
On voit bien
qu'il y a un dialogue
avec l'opposition.
Que les oppositions
à l'Assemblée
ne souhaitent pas dialoguer
et fassent
des obstructions
systématiques qui poussent
le gouvernement au 49.3.
- Alexandre Poussart:
La majorité de droite
du Sénat s'est opposée
à la hausse des dépenses
de santé prévue
par le texte du gouvernement.
Les sénateurs
de droite estiment
que cela va mettre
dans le rouge
les comptes
de la Sécurité sociale.
Est-ce qu'il faut
trouver des économies
dans notre système de santé?
- Xavier Iacovelli:
On ne peut pas vivre
sur un endettement
et un déficit important
de notre financement
de la Sécurité sociale.
Ca a été rappelé
par le ministre,
à la fois la droite
sénatoriale demande
de faire des économies,
refuse de voter
pour 2024...
Ils refusent de voter
cette trajectoire,
et dans le même
temps, ils votent
des milliards de dépenses
supplémentaires...
On voit bien
qu'il y a une incohérence,
une course
à l'échalote
de celui qui fera
le plus de propositions
de dépenses
supplémentaires,
et à la fin,
on dénonce le fait
qu'on ait un déficit
important
sur la Sécurité sociale.
- Kathia Gilder:
Dans le débat,
vous avez proposé
une hausse de taxes
sur les boissons
et les aliments sucrés.
Vos amendements
ont été votés
par une majorité de sénateurs.
Le gouvernement n'y
était pas favorable.
Il a mis en avant le fait
que ça pouvait désavantager
les familles les plus modestes.
- Xavier Iacovelli:
Ce sont des taxes
comportementales.
J'ai fait plusieurs
amendements,
un sur les sodas,
très sucrés,
et un sur les aliments
transformés
avec des additifs de sucre.
Aujourd'hui,
on est dans une situation,
y compris
chez les jeunes,
beaucoup
où on a une augmentation
du surpoids
et de l'obésité.
C'est principalement
dû à un taux
de sucre
dans les aliments
qui n'est pas nécessaire
et qui empoisonne
la santé de nos jeunes
et de nos familles.
La proposition,
c'était à la fois
de surtaxer,
parce que je pense sincèrement
que les boissons
sucrées
ne sont pas essentielles
à notre quotidien,
et que le fait
de taxer un peu
plus les boissons sucrées
nous permet peut-être
de réduire cette consommation.
Les taxes comportementales
ont fonctionné.
Plus on augmente
les taxes sur le tabac,
moins on a de consommation.
Sur la question
des produits sucrés
et des produits
transformés,
c'est une incitation
pour les industriels
à baisser leurs taux de sucre.
Le sucre provoque l'obésité
et le surpoids, aujourd'hui.
Un certain nombre
de produits d'industriels
ont réduit
leur taux de sucre
pour que ce soit un argument
marketing.
Les industriels
sont capables
de le faire.
La proposition
que j'avais faite,
c'était une surtaxe
pour les produits
avec un Nutri-Score
assez haut,
et ceux qui auraient un bon
score pourraient
avoir une taxe moindre.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Des hausses
de taxes
sur les produits sucrés
ont été votées,
mais pas sur l'alcool.
Vous le regrettez?
- Xavier Iacovelli: Oui.
La question de l'alcool,
dans les territoires
de notre pays, est toujours
très compliquée.
On dépose un amendement
avec mes collègues sénateurs
pour ne pas augmenter
les taxes, justement.
On essaye
de faire en sorte
qu'il y ait un prix minimum
pour l'unité d'alcool,
pour éviter
que les produits,
comme le vin étranger,
qui arrivent
en vrac et qui sont vendus
en cubi
à moindre coût,
puissent être à un prix
très peu cher, ce qui incite
à la consommation
des plus modestes,
et surtout des jeunes.
C'est une question
de santé publique.
Que ce soit la taxe
sur les sodas,
sur les produits
transformés
ou sur le prix minimum
pour l'alcool,
c'est une question
de santé publique.
- Kathia Gilder:
Vous avez voté
une taxe lapin
pour pénaliser
ceux qui n'honorent pas
leurs rendez-vous médicaux.
Est-ce que la méthode
du bâton, ça marche?
- Xavier Iacovelli:
Il faut les deux.
Il faut de la pédagogie,
il faut expliquer
que ce sont plusieurs
millions d'euros
que cela coûte
à la Sécurité sociale
sur des rendez-vous
qui ne
sont pas honorés par les patients.
Il y a, je crois,
600.000 personnes
qui n'ont pas de médecin
traitant,
qui n'ont pas de rendez-vous...
C'est aussi
un moyen de lutter
contre les déserts médicaux.
Le temps qui est consacré
à des rendez-vous
qui ne sont pas honorés,
c'est du temps
qu'on pourrait
consacrer à des gens
qui ont vraiment des pathologies.
Pour avoir une taxe,
il faut de la pédagogie,
et il faut le bâton.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Le gouvernement réfléchit
à une hausse
des franchises médicales,
une hausse
du reste à charge
pour les assurés
de la Sécurité sociale,
notamment sur les dépenses
en termes
de médicaments
et de consultation médicale.
En période d'inflation,
ce serait
une bonne idée?
- Xavier Iacovelli:
Cette piste a été lancée
par Aurélien Rousseau
au mois d'août.
J'avais déjà réagi là-dessus.
Sur le principe,
je ne suis pas opposé.
Je pense que ça peut être utile.
Encore une fois,
ça
ne concerne pas les femmes
enceintes,
ça ne concerne pas les mineurs,
et ça
ne concerne pas
non plus les maladies chroniques.
Aurélien Rousseau,
ministre de la Santé,
a permis
dans les arbitrages,
même si ce n'est pas finalisé...
Il avait parlé
d'une augmentation
de 50 centimes
pour les médicaments,
mais en gardant la franchise
qui existe déjà.
Une franchise de 50 euros par an.
On a tous une franchise
de 50 euros
par an.
Au-delà, on ne paye plus les 50
centimes supplémentaires.
Maintenir cette franchise...
Tous ceux qui sont malades
chroniques
ne sont donc pas concernés.
Ils dépassent déjà
la barre des 50 euros
de franchise.
Les femmes enceintes
et les mineurs
ne seront pas concernés.
C'est pour lutter
contre l'excès
de médicaments.
Il y a une consommation
trop importante
de médicaments en France.
- Kathia Gilder:
C'est une source d'économie?
- Xavier Iacovelli:
Tout à fait,
et une question de santé publique.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Dernier sujet d'entretien,
le Sénat a voté
une proposition de loi
pour reconnaître l'injustice
de la criminalisation
de l'homosexualité
entre 1942 et 1982
en France.
Le régime de Vichy
avait interdit
les relations homosexuelles.
La majorité de droite
du Sénat a voté
ce texte, mais s'est opposée
à des réparations financières
pour les personnes victimes.
Réaction de l'auteur
de cette proposition
de loi.
- Pour toutes les personnes
condamnées,
le prix à payer fut lourd.
Si les faits réprimés
étaient assortis d'amendes
ou de courtes
peines de prison,
ces condamnations
constituaient
des taches indélébiles
pour les personnes concernées.
Ces sanctions pénales
allaient de pair
avec l'opprobre social,
l'ostracisation,
le rejet des condamnés
par leur famille...
Elles entraînaient aussi
leur licenciement
ou la ruine de leur carrière
professionnelle.
Ces pertes sociales,
morales et financière
ne sauraient être évaluées.
Ces peines ont marqué
à vie des existences.
Elles firent voler
en éclats des vies
et des familles.
Certains malheureux
furent poussés
au suicide.
La presse étalait
leur identité ou publiait
les photos.
Aucune loi ne sera
en mesure de réparer
ce préjudice.
- Alexandre Poussart:
La majorité
de droite et du centre
du Sénat a reconnu
la faute de la République,
mais a refusé
des réparations
financières
pour les personnes
qui ont été condamnées.
Il en reste une centaine
en vie aujourd'hui.
Vous regrettez
ce vote à mi-chemin
de la majorité sénatoriale?
- Xavier Iacovelli:
Je remercie
mon collègue
Hussein Bourgi
d'avoir porté
cette proposition de loi,
qui a été votée
à l'unanimité,
ce qui n'est pas rien.
C'était important
d'avoir cette loi symbolique
qui reconnaît
la responsabilité
de la République...
- Kathia Gilder:
La faute de la République?
- Xavier Iacovelli:
Oui,
dans cette
discrimination,
qui nous paraît
aujourd'hui incohérente,
mais qui,
il y a encore très peu
de temps, était dans le droit.
Je pense que c'était important.
Sur les réparations,
je n'ai pas complètement suivi
les argumentaires
de ceux qui ont refusé
cette indemnisation,
mais avoir une centaine
de personnes
qui auraient le droit
à cette réparation...
Cette indemnisation
aurait été positive.
- Kathia Gilder:
La procédure est complexe.
- Xavier Iacovelli: Oui,
et il fallait mesurer l'impact...
Le fait d'avoir supprimé
ces articles, notamment
la création d'une commission
qui aurait pu évaluer
à la fois les dommages
moraux et financiers
pour toutes ces personnes,
je pense
que c'est dommage
de ne pas aller jusqu'au bout.
Le débat devra
continuer, notamment
à l'Assemblée nationale.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Cette criminalisation
de l'homosexualité
nous paraît anachronique
en 2023,
mais est-ce que la lutte
contre l'homophobie
est terminée aujourd'hui?
- Xavier Iacovelli: Non.
La lutte
contre toutes les discriminations
est encore d'actualité.
On le voit sur tous les sujets.
Il faut continuer ce combat
contre l'homophobie.
- Kathia Gilder:
Sur ce sujet de l'homophobie,
il y a une polémique
à l'Assemblée nationale.
Le président de la Ligue
de football professionnel
était auditionné
par la commission d'enquête
sur les défaillances
dans le sport.
Il a expliqué
pourquoi les joueurs
ne porteraient
plus de maillot arc-en-ciel
le 17 mai,
opération pour lutter
contre l'homophobie,
et il réfléchit
à une autre opération
car, je le cite,
"la frontière entre lutter
contre l'homophobie
et faire la promotion
de l'homosexualité
est ténue.
Faire la promotion
de l'homosexualité,
ce n'est pas notre boulot."
Est-ce que ces propos
sont homophobes?
- Xavier Iacovelli:
Ils sont clairement
très maladroits, en tout cas.
Je ne connais pas ce président.
Je comprends la polémique
et je comprends
qu'on puisse être choqué
par ces propos.
Je ne sais pas
si c'est volontaire.
On ne fait pas la promotion
de l'homosexualité.
C'est un fait.
Il n'y a pas de promotion
à en faire.
Il y a une lutte
contre l'homophobie
à mener dans tous les milieux.
Le milieu du foot,
qui est très populaire
et très apprécié
dans notre pays,
est un des meilleurs
lieux pour mener
cette lutte.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Il y a un problème d'homophobie
dans le milieu du football?
- Xavier Iacovelli:
Dans le sport
en général.
Il y a de l'homophobie,
mais comme dans tous
les milieux.
Il n'y a pas de milieu
épargné
sur les actes de discrimination
et l'homophobie
en particulier.
- Kathia Gilder:
Merci, Xavier Iacovelli,
d'avoir été notre invité.
- Alexandre Poussart:
A la semaine prochaine.